hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar analysis of the
transcriptome of carriers of
pathological variants in Pristina len1
presa million - and amyloid beta
precursor of protein that caused
Alzheimer's disease I am Judy O'Rourke
of elaborate and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Lex
again Lexington is a transcriptomics and
next-generation sequencing company
focusing on the development of
technologies for complete transcriptome
sequencing its portfolio includes
innovative molecular biology kits
software and services for RNA seek to
learn more visit WWll gen calm let's get
started this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
post questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker Oscar Harari PhD
an assistant professor in the department
of psychiatry at Washington University
in st. Louis
dr. Ferraris research is focused on the
identification of omics factors
implicated in complex neurodegenerative
traits in particular Alzheimer's disease
ad the identification of these genomics
transcriptomics and proteomics factors
and their interplay will help us to
understand the etiology of the disease
and to develop new drugs and their
respective companion diagnostics dr.
Ferrari has employed traditional
biomarkers of Av that is cerebrospinal
fluid a beta to identify a novel
cerebrospinal fluid biomarker the
discovery of biomarkers for AD is a key
to identifying individuals in the
pre-symptomatic stage of the disease
biomarkers can potentially be used
clinically for diagnosis and to track
the effectiveness of novel therapies but
can also be used as Indo phenotypes for
genetic studies leading to the
identification of novel variants and
genes involved in AD and novel
therapeutic targets dr. Horace complete
bio is found on the labyrinth website
dr. Ferrari will now begin his
presentation okay thank you Sam my duty
for your nice presentation and thank you
the people from Lexington a lab route
for enough the chance to share our
research as you might know a sign of
disease is the most common form of
dementia and nowadays there's no
available q eighty fifty megabytes 5.2
million patient just in the US and it is
projected that by 2050 there will be 15
millions of affected subjects it's the
sixth leading cause of death and it's
characterized by a progressive memory
loss and cognitive decline so indeed the
pathology of AD begins it's accepting
orders it begins within 10 to 15 minutes
before we can notice any any decline in
cognition and from the pathological
point of view it is catalyzed by
intracellular angle plaques and
extracellular kuru tangles so in this
chart you can see the different advance
that
well accepted that happens before they
decline recognition so the beginning 15
years before the kind of cognition
amyloid-beta starts propagating to
blocks which it follows by our angles
and that's when there are some symptoms
of cognitive decline and one of the
patient's get that point the the neurons
are already there so all of the
treatments all of our efforts are
towards the identification of the
initial events that lead to this disease
and indeed when I did in Ag we see
another loss and astrocyte proliferation
that's something else that it got is
characteristic of the putter from the
pathological point of AD so there are
different manifestations of a B and the
early onset which is characteristic in
familias it has the Mendelian form of
autosomal dominant AG thanks very well
only one less than 1% of the patients
have this sort of manifestation and it's
usually the case that the symptoms they
cannot be declined appears before the
age of 65 and it tends to be clustering
funded and the research community has
already identified invitations to the
pennant and mutations in the AP PPS one
of these two genes most the most buzz
pejorative the subjects that have AD
have in delayed which quality correlate
of the P P and the H stone sex is higher
than 60 65 in contrast to the Italians
they do have happen to her so made
billion sort of in Hagan's the legs
concert ad is has the capacity of a
complex genetic trait where we have
different genes that confer
different risk that not fully penetrated
with confrontation risk of developing
lady and indeed it's also happy
in families because we have more than
40% of the cases have one or more effect
the first we give relatives and we're
interested in understanding
transcriptome of AD M because that would
give us some insights of the molecular
networks out there by the disease or
causing the disease and even women doing
the escape analysis of skin fibroblasts
we can see that mutation carriers of 80
EPS one people die on a cluster by the
transcriptome machine is capable follow
apart from the first-degree relatives so
this is indicating does an over effect
of this by a discordant variance has an
effect and the other transcriptome so we
this was measured in the skin fiberglass
so we are interested to see what happens
in the transcript on the several cortex
which is in the region of the brain
which is affected by ad so that would
let us understand how their genetic
illness I would 4/10 genome-wide
Association studies for next generation
studies and organized to come on our
distant networks until then learn more
about the disease and be able to
generate some novel targets for the a
drug treatment so one of the problems
while doing transcriptomics analysis is
that as I mentioned in AD there's never
a loss and suicide proliferation so this
different cocktail composition in the
brain will confound
any effect that we finally trask atomic
profiles so for example in this chart
that you can see the top the corner top
right in your screen you would see that
here along the x axis we have the full
change my cochlea comparing the y axis
before change in astrocytes and is
mind that were in deals with in
something response so you might see that
in blue other the genes the transcripts
that have a high fall defense higher for
in both cell types but in green you
would see that does at the jean jacket
does have a differential expression
specific duster sight and smell there's
no difference for microvidia and
conversely you would have the the red
ones as specific for microglia no effect
for the other side so all of these
specific effects will be lost
or will be confounding if we don't
correct for the cell composition that we
observe in brain so there are different
options to do that we can do some sort
in where we isolate the specific cells
from the tissue and then we sequence
that or witnesses are certain they don't
be done or we just can try to ascertain
what notice we can bulk or a seek just
to ascertain the entire admixture
homogeneous tissue and from they are
different computational approaches to
infer expression of each of the cells
cell types that confer that tissue so
basically the idea is that we have a
reference which are sleeves we have to
capture the signature of the different
cell types but using inserting something
falls and then sequencing the also we
capture the expression signature of
faster side so let's just write my
cranium using another than the side and
then with that we conserve the reference
reference panel so with that reference
panel where we know how to employ this
reference panel we can get some
additional and I seek from bulk from
bulk and seek and using computational
methods that are called digital the
convolutions we can infer the distinct
proposed
that we have in the different issues and
we can plug those distant distributions
into our analysis to correct for the
even confirmation and then highlight
then obtain the true transcriptomic
profiles that differ within non demented
console subjects and effective subjects
so the key here the key was doing that
plenty of different the conversion
methods algorithms and publicly
available and they all of them rely on
the external reference panel as I was
mentioning a expression signature of the
different cell types that conform the
dishes interest so it's kind of critical
then to confirm a good reference panels
to so in the brain it'll not a lot of
resources available so all the access a
broad amount of available publicly
available in such a specific expression
data for example we access the gene
expression omnibus and from there we
attempt for mice from the civil context
of my two samples for last recite two
samples for neurons ancestral
oligodendrocytes and to follow my
cochlea those are the cells that should
be interested in further we were able to
access in under in a gene expression is
a study we will do access for more
original astrocytes also formalize and
we also will talk to some human tissue
that included federal court extant
unloved at hippocampus and we realized
that we could also add into this
analysis IPS see that the cells for
example we included from the A&P ad
Advanced medicine partnership ad this
Broad Institute deposited in the portal
to an elasticized own IP SC the raster
site as well as n will put a little cell
lines and idea see the red neurons at
that one ascertain at fifty fifty seven
days and Halliday's old so we have a
very heterogeneous collection of samples
that we needed to some that were not
those were the basic data was obtained
these in different level preparations
and different to consider options such
as buying the deaf parens and so forth
so we decided to recon to say everything
using a same platform or we chose
Salomon
which is a super liner which is really
really fast and produce very good
results
so we measure with we quantify the
transcript on against the a gene a gene
assembly
so here in this plot is a PCA and this
is somehow this is reducing this is
capturing most of the bias that exists
in the overall transcriptome that we
heard in our samples
so the first b6 is most of the buyers
and the second piece is orthogonal to
the first PC that's that's one we say
that the PCA analysis gets rid of the
correlation among the genes or the
transcript but both marking is like 29%
of the bias that we capture in the
sample would we correlate it with the
species of the donor of the sample so
basically on the right in blue color you
will see that the Sunday there are no
circles correspond to MERIS and on the
left in red those samples correspond to
human so basically if you use these data
as it is to discover markers or specific
transcript that would let us pinpoint
different cell test this Isis will be
completely confounded by this which is
of origin of the x-ray of the donors of
the samples so instead what we have done
we access to the literature and pit a
transcript or genes that are not with
specific or tagging different cell types
so we chose five at least five different
genes for each of the service we want we
want to confirm that vary the vast panel
of gene no transcript with tag life and
a cell types so for example we pick DFA
b & XO x co x9 frustr site for news we
we picked 50k and GID one and so on so
forth so we repeat this physical
component analysis but just using these
25 genes and results are completely
different so here you will see that I
didn't now would have a circles for 4m
the circuits of response I don't feel
very much appreciated but it should
correspond to two mice and triangles to
humans and you would see that
all of those are mixed and the color
correspond to the different cell types
so on the extreme far top-right corner
just about those three corresponds to
neurons on the opposite side you would
see in red and of the astrocytes audible
gendercide has plated my digital and my
cochlea are gilded by it this is three
so basically what we can see here is
that once we only focus with a gene that
are known to be tagged in two different
cell types we can cluster the different
cell types themselves and on top of that
what we have done is we projected an
e-cig turned the transcriptome again
something is in someone against the edge
in 18 and projected into the pieces that
we learned from the center specific we
saw that those were in the navel art of
the basically dog did I see balcony see
from homogeneous tu tissue from brain
was was reflected to be conformed with
these different cell types those they're
the result of the we were expecting
actually so once we observe that we said
that we felt that we were ready to use
any the convolution approaches to
evaluate the cell compositions in the
innocent pocket of interest so we have
some other issues that we wanted to have
that panel we wanted to use machine
learning approaches to pick loops not
only that the genes but also the samples
that would confirm the best accuracy
from the convolution and you have to
remember the dimension that we have
defend
labs that produce the samples we have
different species donors of a sample
that indeed some of the samples are from
settle on feathers there's some others
that come in from I after search surgery
in the procession and those are affected
by some other diseases so we just wanted
to get rid of all of those confirming
factors and get there
the brothers but most classic an elder
would produce the best accuracy for the
[ __ ] in the competition so seriously
we needed to define and matric how to
run a life the performance of the
defender completion level so we we opted
to chose to implode the root mean square
error here you can see the formula if
you that are familiar this looks like a
gradient distance covered it for best
number example so we wanted to measure
to give a systematic way of measure in
the era of television including one of
dropping one of the speech of the
samples and and then we wanted to do
this same thing for each of the samples
and then with control mixtures so
basically it's not the same thing to
predict the purity of a sample given
that we know it's handy percent and my
good way or never the fastest I'd
compared to a sample that would mimic
the distortion we observe in brain so we
wanted to levitate so what we have done
is to follow a procedure called li one
now this cross validation procedure were
basically we trained the models using
all but one of the samples and between
the model that samples that was kept
apart is used to test the model so
basically we drank that sample would
wasn't including the testing to see how
well it is predicted and that series
done for each and every sample that
confronts the problem and this is the
results that you can see here that we
have tanked so the y-axis explains the
beauty helm is the percentage of the
stereotypes that was predicted and the
colors are different if an assaultive
cell got word that the predictions of
the difference out that and on the left
you would see all of the astrocytes
which are followed by the macrophage
neurons and I'd leave it on the sides so
this chart is only showing the some
that we kept whether that would mean
square was lower than 0.2 which with
quite a relaxed value so for example the
first column corresponds to an astrocyte
that was predicted to go above 95% of
our become pollution proud to be an
exercise they indeed the as you can see
here in this chart so I refer different
the compilation approaches all of these
are implementing the cell mix package
which is accessible through the our
programming language and the first the
first column it's showing us the overall
for each and every single server does
the word means clever for all of them
and then we also calculated the routine
scale for each of the cell types so the
implementation of cell mix of the method
call semi-supervised non negative and a
negative magic factorization produced
the best the most accurate result the
overall error was lower than zero point
zero seven and we did the mean profile
which is an implementation of the PCA
algorithm and also the digital sorting
algorithm to which here we are showing
it's the one that produce worse
performance so indeed there are that we
have cell phone neurons and astrocytes
are most designs which are followed
followed by oligodendrocyte jean-michel
Delia the sort that would produce the
the most accurate results and we believe
this because of completely different
evolutions microglia that that means
from different agender cells that that's
an completely different transcript
electrophile so as I said these samples
were coming from completely different
labs completely different level
preparations and sequencing depth so we
we asked what was the minimum death to
consume that the minimum number of reads
and we need it to
include two to conform the reference
panel so what we have done is we down
sample which is basically each of the of
speech of the samples the sequences from
each of the samples were done sample to
own it thank 400 K 500,000 which the
sample we have to we have to consider
this is about 0.5 percent of the samples
to be sample different I have at least
20 million reads
so what we have done it with randomly
sample 400 K reads we quantify the
expression and we done all of this
exercise of the leave one out procedure
we quantify the convoluted the cell
composition and then calculate it
correlation within the the full coverage
in the 400 K don't sample representation
of those samples and we observed over
the collation between those two is about
the point R square is about zero point
ninety eight which is quite very very
acceptable and you can see here there
that big day the different subtypes a
color color coded and the sources are so
by different figures belief insecticide
and you might see that there's no bias
there's no specific effects so as I said
we were also interested in ascertaining
a canary like control or known mixture
so basically we wanted to know how well
will this the completion platforms will
perform when we are M mimicking we are
providing a library at mimics what we
expect to see in reality so what we have
done is that traditional meant in
extended ly when a procedure so we
constructed chimeric libraries which
does fund ring it that correspond to the
different for certain types of interest
weary quantify that
cleverly they computed using the
remaining samples and the signal again
using the root-mean-square level and we
have performed this process many many
times just to estimate get the
distribution of the error so just
graphically to understand what how is
their character is constructed so for
example here you have an oligodendrocyte
usually go down the side at which our
sequence and those are facts ended up in
-1 capture and sequence and we have a we
have a band file
this is bound file that has eternity of
the reads for that one so we pick a
number of those reads to confirm a
control percentage of the overall
decision of the Comerica sample we have
done that several times with different
distributions so this is I'm sorry a
person won't be able to be in this table
but this is like ideas says the two
configurations that we thought that we
might give him some other expense we
said the might make sense to find in
this in the cerebellum kinda fender that
tell our context so we repeated that
experiment other set of confirming these
generic libraries using 32 different
configuration distribution was pastor
price of a preventive psychic
neurochemical glia and did that thousand
times just to get a good sample so
Brittany recently so in total we did
32,000 evaluations and because those
were control we knew exactly what to
expect for each of the like libraries we
can compare their composition
percentages against the expected one and
get their there so again we measure the
distance or the accuracy is nearly
square so the overall there
the other error is about 0.07 which is
decomposing a specific for each of the
cell that indeed what we observe is that
their society and their fasteners the
highest one with it then followed by
delegate then decides which is equal to
9 and again the micro-p is the one is
most accurate with this because it's
completely different origin of the
satellite so with those results we were
confident to use that the conclusion
approach over the convolution strategy
to test this in real data so we access
the advanced medicine politic ad ad data
in there to studies a drugs angle it'll
be stable to studies the Mayo Clinic
which includes an answer these subjects
that were certain that the the frontal
Cochrane said I wonder what they were
and time the transcriptome using RNA
seek and those include an 80 80 80
subjects PSP pathological engine and
controls and we also access the Mount
Sinai bring back samples which includes
320 which are only adn controls and also
a machine for different regions of the
toroidal cortex so those include until
your prefrontal cortex the superior
temporal gyrus that have become desires
on the part of replies so in the
discovery what we have now is that with
your clinic we downloaded each of the
dump files the output from the sequencer
we quantify the expression using so on
again and then run there from the
transcription profiles with a combined
loaded to infer the cell composition for
each of the samples and then we apply we
use linear regression models to test
whether there was any difference between
the compositions of controls and AD as
you can see in this chart in group are
the neurons and in astrocytes are they
safar that colored you can see that
there's a significant decrease in the
percentage of naira in the kitchen dosa
norton allows the effect is really
really high it's like the slope of the
linear equations minus 13 and the people
is highly significant and again the
society proliferation which is so hereby
significantly - of course we we learned
which was the copilot to correct for in
this analysis and we we provided for the
gender data death and the ring which
stands for our nativity number which is
a measurement of the quality of DNA that
may be effective along the level
intubation the day or delta procedure
and the model which was basically
predicted the indicate that the model is
we predicted them than where the
percentage of daniel's based on the
decision the covariates
so we one of the one of the great things
about the Mayo Clinic is that they also
produce data for the several cerebellum
and serve animation regional brain
region which is known not to be affected
by D so basically we were not expecting
to see any difference in the server and
when we have done the linear regression
analysis we observe there were no
significant differences you can even see
here the both adn consciously look more
less the same in terms of them and the
percentages of a surface on neurons so
once we observe this we went for
replications and quantify it they can be
a demon sign a great Bank samples those
are more than thousand samples that are
measuring this for different regions and
we only analyzed samples with were
cognitively normal or definite ID we
left apart probable or possible ID which
is a seller classification of logical
classification of
in terms of a beach so we access the BAM
files quantified and again and so on
run our digital conversion platform and
infirmed insert subtype distributions as
you can see in this chart and under
table underneath for each of the four
regions we use of seller systematic
neuronal loss and astrocyte
proliferations
in ad compared to cognitively normal
subjects indeed the region we observed
the highest effect most more significant
effect is the piper control agents for
both astrocytes and neurons so so far
emotional results using ideal sequencing
environment so we what good question
well we could also use non optimal and
they seek to test not only their the
reference panel but also the the samples
that we have interested so we wanted to
cut the rest also the front of temple
the man's brain actually we have in
analysis to try brands and we wanted to
also analyze the brain composition of
different manifestation of IDs you might
be no no I said my talk talking about
the realities we have one of the largest
collection of brains from people that
have a long certainly in this case we
have 25 and we also wanted to compare
the letter society which in this case we
sequence in so optimal condition
satisfied subjects so we wanted to also
to analyze whether any genes specific
effect because our cohort it's confirmed
for example have 24 subject we have
spark IDs they spoke IDs we call them
which was we just know that they're not
knowing by an Associated but conferring
risk for those subjects so those objects
have brains I think just no clear there
we also have a 25 subjects which have
autosomal dominant ID
three-card list of epic imitation stone
to 151 and 152 we also have a subject
carriers of bond accommodations in pindy
336 and 1022 of term 2 which is very
interesting gene because this gene is
associated the binder is that line
coding balancing this gene associated
with Iggy but this gene is not
expressing nails but my criteria
so that's somehow having the set of the
immune system of content disease and we
also have additional samples with
coordinates and condition with genes so
we wanted to know what was it the cell
type the cell composition of the
different samples so we a produce
suboptimal line and I seek a language
using again Salman and the combo loaded
using our platform and observed again
there's a significant difference I can
learn some soil dementia but all of
these brains were ascertain whether from
the parietal lobe so again we see a
significant level loss and astrocyte
fortifications in the palate a lot when
we compare ad versus control so if we
put together value and it also take it
as a honey cake subset that's
significantly different for the 20
controls that we have for both neurons
and astrocytes when we compare the STDs
we see there's no difference from the
temporal dementia at least kinda pay
later there's no difference in the
distribution of nerves but there's a
significant difference in justice sites
so there's also such motivation for
aesthetics in literature indeed we can
see that the clinical dementia rating
it's a clinical score that it's produced
by clinical evaluating the recognition
of the subjects what they are like
so we tested the latest reported
CDR score
with the percentages and plotted those
those personalities so the CBO goes from
zero which is gonna give me normally to
three which is the worst state of the
disease so you can see as the disease of
the cognitive decline progresses the
cause the Conklin progress is the
decline in the percentages or the
proportion of euros a dozen increase in
the proportion of astrocytes that was
significantly associated with here again
with a given geometry significance as I
mentioned we were interested in
analyzing different my suspicion of a
deal we had eighty three subsequent
letters an idea we replicated the
findings that we observed in the
palliative if subjects were replicating
the kinds of we also in the design
select single context areas that we
analyzed from Maya clinic and a most
another Bank
but this introduces said we also saw is
significantly different cell type
composition in AD versus their controls
and we also were able to see this
significant defend defend composition in
a very tidy and this only twenty five
sub-sector a significantly different
there's lower number of neurons and
proportional an increase not a faster
site compared to contract what really
caught our attention is that within
different manifestation of VD when we
compare late onset ad the middle against
Elliott ad here in the last we see that
the proportion the distribution of salt
that is completely different
although the younger this such as has
left a proportion as well as that yet
showing that the defect in this cohort
is completely different
indeed as I mention we wanted to see it
if the weather was some cohort of the
gene-specific effects so we compared the
team that we have 34 carriers of ple
three notations of risk variants we
compare that the decisions third types
of the beam district is to control we
observe that both the neuronal
proportional status all were completely
different controls and we did the same
thing using trunk tool carriers the Gini
clinics in Korea and the present time we
don't see any different certain
composition for disk for this subject
which is really it's really calling our
attention so we want to see whether the
system Pacific differences in Michael
areas you might notice I didn't mention
any any identical way because at the
present and we are not observing
different in the proportions microglia
for none of the objects and cohort we
believe that even different states of
micronesia perhaps we are not building
modeling organ given the proper
references to model microglia and that
requires further analysis from forming a
preference panel using Mike only in
different states activational states but
which is not available nowadays and
indeed we analyze different with
certified STD subjects by the the
mutations in the genes that are lying on
we have served there some specific
effects for journaling that differs from
mopti a seminal scurrilous those are the
three genes one Philippines as readable
STDs so we see that different genes on
petitions different genes are conferring
completely their cell compositions in
the brain in the pareto so just
summarizing this part of the top
analyze different region of the after
several contexts and also the Salem
isn't publicly available high poverty
mystic and we also direct our own so
optimal in Isaac data from the pre
attack we observe specific different
effects first society and composition so
we really want to analyze all of this
work is that we want to analyze the
transcriptome profiles of different
carriers gene of mutations of experience
define genes of leading with Italy and
to do so we need to correct for
different composites or the compositions
so what we did in collaboration with the
people from Lexington we sequence with
produce and I seek for 17 castles of
mutations is one aging associated with
semana pasada dominant ad and we employ
the alexa genkan seek three prime
mesenteric it and produce the million
reads with 50 base per insisting the end
and again this is from the parietal and
weary quantify the expression levels
using again
someone with specific we doing this 18
18 because this disk it is capturing
this 3 3 prime end of the transcript so
with model on the three prime end of the
transcript as a reference for song and
again this the only sequence ps1
carriers so we try to see how how was
that with the dissolve distributions in
the subjects so we analyze the IQR in
the quantile rate but measure of balance
variations within each of the transcript
by its robust for outliers so we observe
that among the 1% of the the transcript
with highest bias there are genes that
are typical markers of
and also typical markers if we extended
to the 5% that the genes with highest IQ
are we all gonna pick additional
Markinson errors and astrocytes so we
know that although those are very
specific it brings the some variation
there so what we have done apply our the
convolution method and we were able to
correct for the different distribution
of compositions of the in the brains of
these participants and what we have done
given that we only have carriers we
apply bait called station network so
basically all of these subjects are
color this one imitation so is selected
all of the genes that were significantly
correlated to ps1 and then fed those
with those genes we run the WGC na with
it gene correlate the correlation
network analysis method with will extend
instead of using the correlation is
going to use another magic which is
called g om support eligible lab
measurements we considered only the
condition but also the consistent
emulation among the difference of genes
to infer this sort of network so here we
are so in the the outcome of this
analysis so this networks then was
pruned we thrown somewhere of the links
within the genes using the gene database
and the mock away all of the node remain
analysis but a huge amount of link was
pruned which produced this network and
in the sense of the networks this one it
is called the links giving this one
color in orange and all of the skin and
all of these genes if we do the pathway
analysis is inflexible date associated
with either gather ethical piercing of
genomes hm
a fee of five no.10 represent out ready
and is highly significant
Lily associating lady even after
multiple cause collection and indeed one
of the positive that we are billing in
the lobbies the late endosome order and
some aspects of day AG and also we could
recover that gene ontology term with
pass make to those collections
remarkably we are not only capturing
these network only Jesus agreed with me
on suit ad also summon dominant ideas
would be PS one of apt but we also
contain additional genes which are
typically associated with the items that
I be with are also higher giving this
chart so it's a conclusion I will exceed
we have devised a reference panel in fur
brains of that composition we provide
replicable results of comparable
composition in different studies we are
consistently observed significant
decreases percentage of nerva
proliferation in the criminal context
but nothing in the third balloon we
unfortunately didn't see began in my
career profession of mammography
MicroStation situation basically the
genes were using to tag not clear it
also tagged macrophage some but we are
not observing an association we were
able to infer some mixtures from very
soft optimal basic data again there's a
clear trend analysis of atala facials
after this is progresses and we learned
that million for sophistries shows large
and a huge amount of neural less
compared to other manifestations of ad
and we also set a chance to carriers do
not show the same cells that and
distribution as other carriers and this
is a bitter that we need to further
replicate to to to more forward and we
also considered correcting for cell
compositions critical to obtain
meaningful result in conservation
networks
from an ASIC and as I said the networks
derive from Megan satirical genes not
only associated with the Mendelian code
some uncommon forms of ID but also with
the late concert ad before finishing
finishing that we like again to find the
people from Lexington that gave us the
chance to work with their kid and that
works to give us the chance to law to
talk about our research and I am part of
the each other laughs I will go over it
also with the course lab and I would
also like to thank our funding agencies
just there and I am happy to take any
questions that you might have thanks
again
thank you dr. Ferrari for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box down by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Ferrari will answer as many
questions as time permits and our first
question is do you still have to correct
the analysis for additional covariance
well that's a good question
we are definitely um we are not
capturing any cessation of the stock
type confirmation of situations that
sauce in association with gender or age
that has the typical factors that would
include you in transcriptomics for
Fergie so yes when you hear how to
correct for those kind of coverage how
to see plasticity of the expression of
genes in a panel author deconvolution
distribution yeah so that's a good
question basically there are some
concerns got even the flexible data site
activation CFIDS again a transcript is
associated with astrocyte
but the the levels expression it's
increased by the activation of faster
site so whether we include that gene in
a world of science panel that means
might be confronting proliferation of
exercise with activation of astrocytes
so to do robustly this sort of analysis
you you need to prove
but those two things are different angle
in our case what we have done is we
repeated this analysis leaving the
public course and equitability genes
apart and performing again and again
again the same analysis and we obtain
similar results showing that this
reference panel is robust to the
plasticity of the expression as we deal
with certain biological processes
how could single-cell RNA sequencing
improve and augment your analyses
that's a great question definitely we
are working heavily to include
single-cell sequencing because that
would let you not only to measure the
transcriptome from each cell that also
from the measured atom each of the many
molecules by themselves for with that
information we will be able to do what's
called deep the convolution which is not
only predict the composition of letters
but just to vary the composition of very
specific types of errors so we are
working heavily to getting the data to
generate those kind of model what were
the differences between a co-expression
network analysis and beta network
analysis yeah the covered special arises
usually the case that do you have in
subjects attributes of samples with
different statuses so in an unsupervised
way you infer the network and then you
pick the networks that I associated
using correlation for example with the
status or anything except of interest in
the weight network analysis it is
because of the flexibility of this
package so we managed mention that the
CCNA
allows you to test analyze the
transcriptional context of one gene of
interest you know what case was this one
thank you I would like to once again to
thank dr. Ferrari for his presentation
do you have any final comments could you
so much I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we do
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker by email
we would like to thank our sponsor
lexington for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
December 8 2017 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues whom you
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye thank you